voilà je suis assez d'accord le dernier
mot aux historiens peut-être on passe
maintenant aux élections européennes
alors qu'elles sont loin c'est dans huit
mois
on vous pose la question d'un point de
vue savez vous déjà pour qui vous
voterez à ce sujet le figaro publie
demain les résultats d'un premier
sondage aux hawks a donc bien sûr ce
n'est qu'un baromètre mais ils donnent
des indications intéressantes
on vous en dévoile une le rassemblement
national
nous voulons donc du front national
talonne la république en marche et le
modem associés il est à 21% alors que
république en marche et modem font 21
ans et demi pour cent à eux deux alors
une question déjà toute simple est ce
que ça vous surprend yvan ce résultat à
huit mois des élections vous allez me
dire c'est loin maintenant bien d'en
parler lyon ça ne me surprend pas parce
que moi je reprends dans le fond là
l'opposition qui a été proposée par le
président de la république entre les
progressistes et ce qu'il appelle les
conservateurs parfois il les appelle les
populistes moi je me range très
volontiers dans le camp des
conservateurs ça ne vous étonnera
peut-être pas voir même des populistes
si vraiment les populistes cela veut
dire redonner la place et la parole au
peuple ou peuple je ne pense pas faire
avoir un scoop on en est là dedans
et donc je crois que en effet les
élections les élections européennes vont
se fracturer sur ce sur ce thème là me
semble-t-il et mais simplement les
conservateurs cela cela englobe non
seulement la droite républicaine mais
c'est là englobe également également
l'extrême droite donc quand vous voyez
que la fois le goût le fonde le
rassemblement national
quand oui l'europe semble nation
rassemblement national plus les
républicains informe maintenant j'ai
plus exactement les messages très
largement déjà la majorité ou ans
s'imagine s'il faisait cause commune
le raz-de-marée qui cela pourrait
procurer donc voilà semblement national
de 21 public un certain 14 sont très
largement en tête si on est debout la
france encore plus donc voyez bien que
toute cette droite là qui pour l'instant
est disséminée si elle arrivait à ceux à
s'accorder à se coordonner dans ce grand
don dans ce grand rassemblement 10 10
les conservateurs que j'appelle de mes
voeux clarifierait naturellement les
choses et l'on verrait que effectivement
le camp progressiste un camp qui est
devenu très minoritaires et que le vent
de l'histoire porte de ces populistes
l'acquis pour moi encore une fois ne
sont pas des fascistes
fasciste je ne les aime pas plus que
vous mais simplement les populistes
m'intéresse beaucoup dans la mesure où
ils réveillent la démocratie on verra un
peu plus tard ce que le sondage donne
aussi quelques indications sur les
motivations du vote face sur les thèmes
qui on en parle dans un stand juste
lucide mais je vous réponds d avance sur
le côté sur lequel vous n'êtes pas tout
à fait sur la même longueur d'onde
alors la question que nous aviez posé
c'était quand même pour qui est ce qu'on
serait prêts à voter et j'ai trouvé que
c'était une question très très sympa
très iconoclaste moi j'avais envie de
répondre que j'avais envie de voter pour
x parce que quand je regarde ce sondage
est temps qu'on veuille en des
convictions écologistes étant plutôt de
gauche
évidemment je ne trouve pas ma part
là-dedans parce que bon c'est vrai que
europe écologie les verts et à un score
absolument très petit alors qu'en même
temps depuis la démission de nicolas
hulot on voit que il ya quelque chose
qui s'est structuré politiquement autour
du débat et on voit bien qu après la
halle été de canicule qu'on vient de
vivre cette question cette émergence
politique de l'écologie elle est dans le
débat mais les parts présentes
électorale m'a encore moi j'aspire à x
et je voudrais quand même fait remarquer
qu'à mon avis pour l'instant à 8 mois le
ni droite ni gauche ça fonctionne
exclusivement pour renforcer la droite
voire l'extrême droite où le
conservatisme populiste et que ça
détruit la gauche or je ne suis pas sûr
on parle ensuite du plan pauvreté des
manuels mâcon je ne suis pas sûr en fait
que le le clivage gauche droite ne soit
pas en train de réapparaître assez
fortement et je trouve que les sondages
aujourd'hui ne rendent pas compte de ça
et de choses sans doute qu'ils sont
souterraines mais qui se révéleront je
pense dans huit mois ou avant d'ailleurs
peut-être d'ici la fin de l'année sur
l'écologie sur la différence entre la
gauche et la droite
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de gens qui
se disent mais je ne sais vraiment pas
pour qui voter
et peut-être même pas qu'ils vivent
voilà et peut-être même qui se plaint ce
temps ils disent qu'ils vont voter pour
la république en marche et le modem est
enfin là richard ferrand a été très mal
élue à l'assemblée nationale notamment
le candidat modem a fait un très gros
score
on voit bien que même cette alliance de
la république en marché du modem elle
est en train d'avoir du plomb dans l
aile donc on voit qu'il ya une
reconfiguration politique qui va se
produire et je pense que le sondage
aujourd'hui il montre en creux que c'est
pas possible c'est pas comme ça du tout
que ça va se passer
nicolas vidal sur ça et puis on peut
être élargie aux aussi un petit peu à ce
qui vient
passer à
a strasbourg le vote de la droite
européenne contre hors balais l'article
moi je vais être très clair je suis
profondément européen ça c'est sûr c'est
une certitude
mon père polonais ma mère italienne donc
je suis nous avons fait en france au fil
de l'eau fil des ans des dizaines
d'années mais aujourd'hui je pense
qu'une aspiration souverainiste forte je
suis d'accord une nouvelle fois avec
tibia andrew hall cette polarisation je
suis désolé cher ami je sais bien je
n'aurais pas faire pas je n'aurai pas
certification idéologique ou là que je
vais avoir une contravention idéologique
un petit mathieu bock-côté je sais pas
mais mais pas que à la question pour qui
voteriez-vous je vais voter pour un pour
un parti ou des gens qui vont respecter
la souveraineté des peuples
voilà effectivement je suis d'accord
avec vous il n'y a pas forcément
aujourd'hui sur l'échiquier politique
des gens qui peuvent correspondre à ça
voilà on a vu l'effondrement sol eu de
paix nous accord je crois pour dire ça
effectivement aujourd'hui il faudrait
que des gens qu'ils soient qu'ils se
soient durs assemblée nationale il est
quand même étonnant qu'il est il
étonnant mais parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il me semble t'il
c'est pour la population qui est en
train de se rendre compte qu'il ya eu
vraiment un déni de démocratie de la
part de bruxelles
concrètement des démocraties d'ailleurs
j'avais fait une tribune au figaro sur
les gaulois réfractaires de macron ou où
les peuples je crois que l'europe ne se
fera plus sans les peuples
l'europe ne se fera plus contre les
peuples voilà et je crois que ce clivage
là est extrêmement important et les
élections de mai 2010 neuf sont
cruciales pour moi elles sont cruciales
et on verra on verra si
le peuple français prend conscience de
toute l'ampleur et de toute la structure
crucial de cette élection en mai 2010
quelques réactions en tout cas déjà le
résultat du vote de la question quand
vous posez sur twitter savez-vous pour
qui vous voterez aux élections en mai
2009 et bien vous êtes 63% à dire que
oui et catherine nous dit elle ajoute
juste à l'instant j'espère vraiment que
le mouvement en marche perdra c'est son
opinion marque juste avant de vous
donner la parole je voudrais qu'on donne
un autre élément de réflexion
c'est effectivement les domaines qui
compteront le plus dans le vote
question composé et bien on s'aperçoit
que les thèmes ils sont exclusivement
franco français
tout dépend ce qu'on enfin non c'est pas
vrai parce que l'immigration mais en
tout cas c'est quand même le pouvoir
d'achat qui arrive en tête et donc
l'europe à part pour l'immigration elle
intervient évidemment dans ces thèmes
mais c'est pas le plus déterminant non
surprise pas surprises n'ont pas surpris
ça correspond assez au domaine de
préoccupation des français ce jour de
vie maintenant que je me suis quand vous
voyez les thèmes un peu plus tôt je me
suis penché sur quel est l état des
zèbres a patiemment privilégiées non moi
c'est un peu avant on allait thème avant
les découvre pas sur le plateau j'ai
regardé qu'il a dévoilées pas tout les
fidèles de quels étaient les des
sondages neuf mois avant l'élection
présidentielle
c'est bien parfois là bas alain juppé
était président de la république
j'allais dire nicolas sarkozy ce que je
les confonds emmanuel macron était était
était ministre de l'économie voire pas
candidat france où tout le monde se
demandait si françois hollande allait
être candidat et françois fillon
personne n'en parlait est ce que tout le
monde se le ridiculisant bien ce mec
n'existe pas donc c'est très compliqué
de se projeter gira neuf mois d'une
élection pour savoir quels seront les
thèmes qui dans neuf mois seront dans
l'actualité parce qu'il faut pas se
leurrer les gens voteront en mai 2001 ce
truc que les élections européennes
scrutin où l'engin nationale passe
d'ailleurs tout le monde s'en fout je
veux dire c'est l'élection mais on ira
c'est là qu'ils sélection où on vote le
moins j'ai pas sûr que tout le monde
foot moi aussi parce que je crois qu'il
est une dramatisation autour de cette
aide en parlera avec contreras
c'est tellement bas qu'on sait tellement
impliqué dans cette élection que cela
risque de devenir également une sorte de
35 % de participation
je ne suis pas sûr il faut se rappeler
qu'en 2014
le front national avait fait un très
gros score aux élections européennes il
avait gagné et je pense que je vous
rejoins sur l'idée que la nation
continue à être une question ouverte
dans et que la façon dont emmanuel
macron ont fait présente l'europe d'une
manière très conceptuel extrêmement
abstraite et quelque part dont il n'a
pas réussi pour l'instant à créer des
alliances force niveau gouvernemental
marché pour vous et puis il en gala
merkel lui dit plus tôt son jeu il ya
aussi le break site et donc il ya
quelque chose sur le fait d'inventer une
autre europe qui soient compatibles avec
cette pensée la nation et pour l'instant
vous allez l'avoir 20 ans qu'on entend
c'est donc la fin j'étais pas ce point
de vue il ya 20 ans n'arrête jamais vous
aimez mais je pense que peut-être que
c'est le moment parce que sinon il ya
quand même des gens qui disent ça va
être la dernière élection européenne et
après l'europe va disparaître en tant
qu'institution et aujourd'hui marqueur
fort vous avez l'élection de matteo
salvini en italie sur balles et qui
reprend le solide et c'est à dire que il
reprend les déclarations de mussolini
donc la question du fascisme allait
quand même posé durant je crois qu'on
doit revenir toujours au peuple
on doit revenir toujours au peuple et à
notre riche vous avez le chansonnier
vous l'avez dit aussi macron est
toujours suis seul sur le front de
l'europe
seul parce que merkel est en train de se
rendre compte qu'il ya un vrai problème
et le sondage nous avons vu sur le
pouvoir d'achat et nous en prendrons le
plan pauvreté cette politique
ultralibérale et l'immigration
il ya aujourd'hui l'aquarius a fait a
fait basculer l'opinion publique ou du
moins à accélérer la prise de conscience
du problème migratoire je le pense
voilà donc c'est pour ça que mon avis je
crois que les dés sont pas jetés parce
que c'est jamais jeter il ya une prise
de conscience populaire qui me semble
qu'ils devraient qui devrait être
importante en mai 2007 une dernière
chose à marie émilie excusez moi mais
c'est que le break si le break site
c'est fin mars et donc moi je crois je
suis d'accord avec ivan lins service est
à noter
sur l'un d'eux a veillé sur le fait que
sur cette question des élections
européennes moi je ne crois pas une
abstention forte je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va monter en puissance
et que ça sera peut-être enfin quelque
part une vraie élection de débats
d'autant que la question centrale qui va
être posée outre celle de macron qui
s'est mis en tête de liste c'est de
savoir si oui ou non nous sommes prêts à
régler cette question de civilisation
parce que c'est ceci aujourd'hui qui est
posée bien au delà du pouvoir d'achat le
pouvoir d'achat c'est une chose
naturellement que je ne pense pas que ce
soit prioritaire en tout cas c'est pas
ce qui apparaît au coeur même de toutes
les eaux les enquêtes d'opinion et des
des votes que l'on peut a observé en
europe
aujourd'hui c'est la question de la
civilisation est ce que nous sommes
encore une europe qui veut faire re
peuple qui est qu' une europe qui avec
une cohésion une cohésion historique une
cohésion culturelle ou est ce que nous
devenons un pays lundi culturel qui
était tel que l'or l'union européenne
actuelle est vrai que nous nous soyons
et donc c'est cette question là qui doit
être résolu et elle sera résolue avec
ses european et je pense que ça c'est
vraiment un enjeu qui risque de
mobiliser contrairement ce que je pense
et je pense qu'il risque de mobiliser
les électeurs
à propos de cohésion viktor orban il ya
deux jours vous votiez pour l'exclusion
réputé gros contrat je ne votaient pas
pour l'exclusion viktor orban d'ailleurs
je pense que c'est d'ailleurs c'était
une très mauvaise
c'est officiel c'est un mauvais signal
que lance la droite qui est killer si on
suit les lignes mais a priori scénariste
ken épisode qui est en s macro knees et
si vraiment la droite française tente de
ce maquereau knees et le front national
heureux et le rassemblement national a
déjà à gagner il remportera la timbale
c'est évident donc là il ya une d'un
défaut d'analysé ce que je ne comprends
pas afin que je comprends bien
malheureusement de la part de cette
droite qui est toujours quelqu'un qui
mérite toujours d'être qualifié de la
plus bête du monde parce qu'il ya une
sorte de pression et maquereau a gagné à
une incontestable le mandant c'est dans
ce premier bras de fer mais ce n'est
qu'un premier bras de fer oui si la
dernière haie dire c'est qu'il faut pas
laisser non plus emmanuel macron dicter
les termes ce débat européen il a dit
que c'était progressiste contre
populiste moi personnellement je vois
beaucoup d'autres débats possible à
traiter au niveau européen sur la
question écologique il est clair que
l'europe par exemple a été un fer de
lance là dessus sur les questions
environnementales et que ce n'est plus
le cas aujourd'hui donc il ya un sujet
transformation du modèle et comment est
ce qu'on fait l'investissement
économique nécessaire
il ya un sujet europe versus reste du
monde la question américaine quel est
notre pouvoir de peser et puis je
voudrais quand même dire une chose c'est
que l'europe certes j'entends bien
l'idée de la cohérence mais la façon
dont elles ne pensent pas sa relation au
sud explique aussi pourquoi face à la
question migratoire elle est totalement
divisée nous pensons de plus en plus
l'europe de l'est parce qu'il ya un
tropisme allemand mais sur la question
algérienne sur la question africaine sur
la façon dont l'europe doit s'impliquer
sur la question des pays en
développement il ya une béance et la
france qui longtemps a joué un rôle là
dessus aujourd'hui ne joue plus donc je
trouve que sur la question de la grèce
par exemple ya des choses très
importantes y compris les états du sud
qui sont au sein de l'europe ont le
sentiment d'être aujourd'hui orphelins
et ça donne la matteo salvini un espace
immense parce que il ya une absence de
politique européenne sur l'italie sur la
grèce et sur les pays de la méditerranée
arnaud dit avec un peu d'ironie et si
nous votons populiste quels seront les
punitions contre la france de la part de
l'europe et le commentaire c'est le nom
notre interview sur effectivement quel
est le programme de macron sur le
chômage le pouvoir d'achat l'immigration
la sécurité et l'islam en france
interrogations il n'a pas dit
l'environnement non il a oublié de
parler de vous voulez vous c'est
peut-être volontaire c'est pas dans la
liste à l'écologie l'écologie est
devenue un conservatisme normalement si
vous acceptez 7
un sujet à part vous devriez nous
rejoindre car force est forcément
écologistes alors si on peut parler
aussi un peu du plan pauvreté alors la
partie n'a un euro mais aussi un service